Bon écoute-moi bien Moreno.
Sache qu'on a assez d'éléments contre toi pour que tu puisses plus voir le jour pendant un bon petit moment.
Et surtout...
On sait que lors du cass, t'étais pas tout seul.
Ok.
Je vois...
P'tit café?
Je bois pas de café.
Ok.
Ca te parle ça, non ? C'est de chez toi.
Et si on se fumait un petit cigarillo tout les deux?
Comme des potes. Histoire de...
Je fume pas.
Là ça me vexe.
Et pas qu'un peu.
Ce que t'as pas compris Moreno...
C'est que moi, contrairement à toi, je suis payé pour être là.
Donc j'ai tout mon temps, mais alors tout mon temps.
Euh, c'est pas ce que dit le planning là.
Y a écrit que vous êtes censé finir à 18h.
Cherche pas, c'est un ancien planning ça.
Bon, tu me fais perdre mon temps Moreno.
T'es parti pour 15 ans fermes minimum,
Et une fois en prison, tu diras " eh si j'avais su, j'aurai dénoncer mon pote",
Sauf qu'il sera trop tard !
Ah, c'est pour ça le café et tout...
Vous voulez que je balance mon associé.
J'peux même pas... Mais après c'était pas super clair quoi...
Vous avez pas dit une fois le mot...
Associé déjà...
Z'avez dit café.
Je comprends effectivement que c'était pas tout à fait bien amené...
J'crois pas...
J't'écoute...
Ok, je le connais pas vraiment...
C'est un mec super discret, il a pas un, mais des pseudos.
Tu pourrais nous le décrire?
Ouais, ça je peux ouais.
Envoyez-moi le portraitiste.
Tu peux y aller.
Alors il est blanc, trente ans...
Blond, les cheveux clairsemés.
Il a des lunettes rondes,
Et il a une boucle d'oreille.
C'est tout ?
Il a une cicatrice.
Il a une grosse cicatrice sur la joue droite.
C'est tout ce dont je me souviens...
Merci d'avoir coopéré Moreno.
Est-ce que c'est lui?
Non.
Lui?
Non, mais j'avais dit des lunettes rondes...
Non mais... jeune surtout !
Là c'est un vieux.
Et j'avais dit une cicatrice.
Mais c'est Harry Potter....
Non mais là, c'est...c'est un paysage le mec...
Tu me... C'est même plus des portraits ce que tu me montres là !
Regardez vous-même.
Mais là, c'est...c'est un paysage le mec...
C'est même plus des portraits ce que tu me montres là !
Regardez vous-même.
Tenez-vous en a la description.
Merci.
On est sur le point d'avoir le portrait du suspect, envoyez des hommes.
C'est lui !
Arrêtez-le !
Non !
Non, non, non non non !
Non !!
Ta gueule !
Non, lâchez-moi !!